papa qu'est ce qui t'arrive chercher un
coach est donc le conseil de famille
propose de vous confier un petit garçon
nous sommes face à un cas assez
particulier vous vous étiez plutôt
ouvert je vous présente un chemin
sesmat quoique j'ai fait assez j'aurais
dû sera de marquer bonjour moi que je
dise quelque chose ils t'ont donné un
congolais
dis moi juste comme anquetil ami n'est
pas un congolais jeter vix appelé
benjamin mais s'appelle la vie de la
mine combles perdus ousmane pendant le
grand père de ousmane et qu'on l'arrière
grand père de ousmane c'est la tradition
la tradition même salle
bonjour c'est quoi ça c'est benjamin à
haussmann
pourquoi ne faut pas s'appeler la mine
j'avais dû faire une blague expo
nous on s'occupe des enfants de leur
trouver une famille adéquat pas de faire
des expérimentations
la tradition c'est quand même de donner
un bébé noir et blanc ils ont fumé quoi
la dass
n'oubliez pas j'ai hâte de rencontrer
beaucoup ça va être un peu compliqué je
pense a vécu là bas il y à la noyade le
tout halal et yamcha tonnes per talent
bonsoir hollande ces mots qui changent
le monde la première famille benetton
benjamin la maman n'a pas pu gagner mais
c'est moi la maman ah oui non mais c'est
ce qu'il est très mignon eh bien vous
vous aussi on y va voilà c'est nous et
ensuite ce sera à nous sommes super